FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. WE HAVE A LIMITED
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND WE
ARE HEARING TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
OUR NORMAL PRACTICES. SO THAT
THE PUBLIC CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL SOME OF
OUR- I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WILL
BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- NO
IN FACT TODAY ALL MEMBERS WILL
BE PARTICIPATING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
HOWEVER WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND- AS THEY KNOW
THEY SHOULD MUTE THEIR PHONES
OR COMPUTERS- TO ILLUMINATE THE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND TO USE
THEIR- RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE.
SO THAT. WHEN THEY WANT TO
SPEAK SO THAT I CAN THEN
RECOGNIZE THEM WITH THE RAISE
YOUR HAND. NOW TO ALLOW ACCESS
TO THE PUBLIC WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWED. WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY. SO FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO TESTIFY BY
TELEPHONE. THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS ON THE
SENATE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WILL
ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. IT
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SIX ONE
ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID A
CUE STICK FEEDBACK MUTE YOUR
DEVICE- PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. AND WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF
OUR ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT WE CAN HERE FOR
EVERYONE- MR SHIPP STEPPING
CHAU DO WE HAVE A QUORUM. NOT
YET ALL RIGHT SO. I'M I CANNOT
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AS OF YET
BUT I CAN BEGIN. AS A- A
SUBCOMMITTEE IN EFFECT TO BEGIN
THE HEARING- AND BEFORE WE HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LET ME GIVE YOU THE OVERVIEW
MEMBERS OF WHAT WE ARE DOING
TODAY. WE HAVE THREE BILLS. WE
HAVE PAID SICK LEAVE AND TO
CLEAN UP BILLS ON PREVIOUS
EARLY ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN. THESE ARE A CONTINUATION
OF THE- HI MINUTE STOP BECAUSE
I CAN NOW ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO
COMMITTEE- TWENTY SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
SKINNER I'M HERE. SKINNER HERE
SENATOR NELSON. SINNER
CABALLERO. SYNDERGAARD CORTESE
PRETTY EASY HERE SENATE DOLLY.
CENTER DORADO RATHER HERE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN HERE CENTER
GROVE. ROVERE CENTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HERE SOONER LATER.
THEY'RE HERE SAM REQUIRE.
CENTER MELENDEZ MULLIN IS HERE
CENTER MEN I MEAN HERE CENTER
NEWMAN. CENTER HOTEL. THE
TROUBLE HERE CENTER PATIENT
CARE CLEAN HERE CENTER STERN.
SIR WHAT KASKY. SO WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A CORPSMAN LET ME
WELCOME OUR NEW COMMITTEE
MEMBER SENATOR COMELEC WELCOME
SO NOW LET ME TO CONTINUE. R.
AS I INDICATED WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US TODAY OR CONTINUATION
OF THE EARLY BUDGET ACTIONS
WE'VE BEEN TAKING TO SUPPORT
OUR STATE'S ONGOING RESPONSE TO
THE PANDEMIC. AND THESE EARLY
ACTIONS SO FAR HAVE INCLUDED
DEPLOYING ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
BILLION IN RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
SUPPORT OUR SMALL LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN. PAGE DUE TO
THEIR TENANTS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC. HARDSHIP AND TO
SUPPORT OF COURSE ARE TURNED
INTO A BIG MEN EXPERIENCING
THAT ECONOMIC HARDSHIP AND WE
ALSO IN THE SAME ACTIONS
EXTENDED OUR EVICTION
PROTECTIONS WE EXPANDED OUR
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS AND ARE
PROVIDING NOW TWO POINT ONE
BILLION IN SUPPORT TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS THAT
HAVE BEEN HURT BY THIS PANDEMIC.
AND HAVE. ACTED ON THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION IN DIRECT
STIMULUS FUNDS FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO OUR LOWEST
INCOME RESIDENTS AND TO
RESIDENTS WHO DID NOT BENEFIT
FROM PREVIOUS FEDERAL STIMULUS.
ARENDT WE HAVE AUTHORIZED SIX
POINT SIX BILLION TO HELP OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. RETURN TO THE
CLASSROOM FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND PROVIDE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION IN
SUPPORT THAT IS NEEDED. AS
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
RECOVER FROM THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. NOW TWO DAYS PAID
SICK LEAVE BILL AB EIGHTY FOUR
IS PART OF AN AGREEMENT TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
OUR BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES.
UNTIL THE BILL UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PROVIDES EIGHTY HOURS OF PAID
LEAVE. TO EMPLOYEES TO CARE
FROM THEIR SELVES OR FAMILY
MEMBERS DUE TO COBIT. COVERT
SYMPTOMS QUARANTINE TREATMENT
VACCINATION AND VACCINE
RESPONSE. AND THIS PROVIDES
PAID LEAVE FOR EMPLOYEES TO
CARE FOR SPECIFIED FAMILY
MEMBES WHO MAY HAVE TO
QUARANTINE DUE TO COPE IT OR TO
TAKE CARE OF A CHILD. WHO
SCHOOL OR PLACE OF CARE IS
CLOSED. DUE TO COBIT. THIS
ACTION EXCLUDES BUSINESSES IN
TERMS OF IT BEING MANDATORY
WITH TWENTY FIVE OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES HOWEVER. THE TAX
CREDITS WHICH I'M ABOUT TO
DESCRIBE PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THOSE BUSINESSES
WITH TWENTY FIVE OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES. SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE OF COURSE ALL
BUSINESSES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT. BECAUSE THIS ACTION
RESULTS IN VIRTUALLY NO COST TO
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT THE NOTICE TO TAX
CREDIT ON PAYROLL TAXES. NO
IT'S PART OF THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN OUR- TWO HOUSES AND THE
GOVERNOR WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. SOME TAX CONFORMITY FOR THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM BUT
WE HAVE DELAYED THAT ACTION AS
WE SEEK FEDERAL GUIDANCE
REGARDING SOME PROVISIONS IN
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN THAT
WAS RECENTLY PASSED. THAT WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANY ACTION
WE TAKE DOES NOT JEOPARDIZE THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO. FULLY
ACCESS ALL OF THE FUNDING THAT
THAT RECOVERY ACT HAS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE ARE STILL
SEEKING GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDS
FOR THAT. WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY AFTER HEARING ALL
THREE OF THE BILLS AND THEN THE
VOTE WILL BE TAKEN ON THE BILLS
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM OUR-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
LOOKING TO SEE IF OUR VICE
CHAIRS HERE HAVEN'T SEEN HIM
NOT IN THE ROOM YET I WILL
ALLOW HIM TO MAKE COMMENTS
LATER. SO LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF OUR FIRST BILL
AB EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS THE
CLEAN UP TO THE LICENSE RENEWAL
FEES BILL AND I DIDN'T DESCRIBE
THAT AS PART OF OUR EARLY
ACTIONS BUT AS YOU KNOW. ONE OF
THE ADDITIONAL EARLY ACTIONS
THAT WE TOOK TO SUPPORT OUR-
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WAS TO
SUSPEND CERTAIN LICENSE
PAYMENTS FOR THEM AND THIS BILL
IS CLEANING UP SOME OF THAT SIR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU MAY
PLEASE PRESENT. ON AB EIGHTY
THREE. GREAT GOOD MORNING CHAIR
SKINNER VICE CHAIR NELSON
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ONLY JARVIS WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AND EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE IS RELATED TO FEE WAIVERS
FOR SPECIFIC BUSINESSES
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE AND THEN SB
NINETY FOUR WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW ON FEBRUARY REVISED
ECONOMIC RELIEF TO LICENSEES OF
THE DEPARTMENT ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL PRIMARILY BARS
AND RESTAURANTS THAT WERE
HARDEST HIT BY THE OPERATIONAL
IMPACT. ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ORDERS ISSUED TO
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF UP IN
NINETEEN. EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE
ADDS THREE ADDITIONAL LICENSE
RIGHT SMALL WINEGROWERS SMALL
BEER MANUFACTURERS AND CRAFT
DISTILLERS TO THOSE TWENTY
SEVEN TYPE OPERATION SB NINETY
FOUR. JURIES THE WAIVERS FOR
ANNUAL LICENSING FEES. WE
ESTIMATE THESE WAIVERS WILL
PROVIDE ECONOMIC RELIEF TO
APPROXIMATELY. FIVE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY ADDITIONAL
LICENSE FEES INCLUDING ABOUT
FORTY TWO HUNDRED WINEGROWERS
TO PRODUCE. A LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS OF
WINE PER YEAR. ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED SMALL BEER
MANUFACTURERS AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY CRAFT
DISTILLERS. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO BACK
THE LAST SPECIAL FRIEND REVENUE
THAT LICENSEES OTHERWISE PAGE
NOT APARTMENT. THE PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ORIGINAL
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE ECONOMIC
RELIEF TO THE LICENSEES HARDEST
HIT. BY THE CODE NINETEEN
BENJAMIN. NECKING WITH MY- I'M
AVAIL FOR FASTER. WHAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- R. MISTER URBIS
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LET'S
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COLLEAGUES ABOUT THIS-
ADDITION TO OUR- BUSINESSES
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FUNERAL ANY QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS- SEEING NINE- WE WILL.
DOCTOR TO TAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
THE ENTIRETY SAID THAT SO I'M
JUST REMINDING MYSELF- SO WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PRESENTATION
ON THE NEXT BILL WHICH IS AB
EIGHTY FOUR THAT'S THE
SUPPLEMENTAL. PAID SICK LEAVE
THAT I DESCRIBED SO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PLEASE PROCEED ON AB
EIGHTY FOUR. RIGHT THANK YOU.
THIS BILL REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE UP TO EIGHTY THE
COMPANY TEAMS UP WITH NO PAID
SICK LEAVE TO ALL EMPLOYEES
SEPTEMBER THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HOWEVER EXEMPTS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND EMPLOYERS WITH
TWENTY FIVE OR FEWER EMPLOYEES.
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
RETROACTIVE TO SICK LEAVE TAKEN
BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND PROVIDES COVER
NINETEEN SUPPLEMENT PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND WEBER PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES PROVIDER'S.
ELIGIBILITY IS SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS LATELY ENACTED STATUTE
THAT EXPIRED IN DECEMBER ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY HOWEVER THIS BILL ADDS-
AND ADDS. THAT ELIGIBILITY FOR
APPOINTMENTS FOR KOBE NINETEEN
VACCINE OR FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS RELATED
TO THE BACKSEAT. AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION I
CHRIS COOK IS WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU ANDESITE
POINTED OUT. WHILE THE BILL
DOES NOT MANDATE THE
PARTICIPATION OF EMPLOYERS OF
IMPACT TWENTY FIVE OR LESS
EMPLOYEES. IT IS STILL
SOMETHING AVAILABLE TO THOSE
EMPLOYERS BECAUSE THE TAX
CREDITS THAT THE FEDS HAVE MADE
AVAILABLE. WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
UTILIZED BY THAT EMPLOYER SO IF
THAT EMPLOYER WANTS TO EXTEND.
THIS THE BENEFIT. TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES THEY CERTAINLY MAY-
SENATOR GROW DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT I DO MADAM
CHAIR GO AHEAD HERE I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I HAVE AND
I HAVE HUGE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL- ONE OF THE MAIN ISSUES
THAT I HAVE IS. I'D LIKE
SOMEBODY TO ADDRESS THE
RETROACTIVITY. SO THIS BILL- IS
RETROACTIVE TO JANUARY FIRST
AND BY THE TIME THIS BILL GETS
ASSIGNED IF WHEN IT PASSES IT
WILL BE PROBABLY MARCH I DON'T
KNOW. NEXT MONDAY IS WHAT I'M
THINKING. WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THIS CALENDAR YEAR
EMPLOYED PEOPLE FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWO WHATEVER THE BILL
SIGNING DATE IS IN THIS BILL
RETROACTIVELY MAKES THIS A
JANUARY FIRST COMPLIANCE TO
EMPLOYERS WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDS FOR
CEMENT TO ENFORCE- A BILL
EMPLOYERS THAT WAS NOT YET IN
EXISTENCE. BUT REQUIRES
ATTENTION TO COMPLY
RETROACTIVELY. THE REASON WHY I
HAVE A CONCERN WITH THAT NOT
ONLY BECAUSE THE PREMISE OF THE
BILL BUT ALSO THERE IS A BILL
GOING TO THIS BUILDING THAT IS
GOING TO PUT. EMPLOYERS IN JAIL
FOR WHAT IS CONSIDERED WAGE
THEFT OR NOT PAYING EMPLOYEES
ARE PROPERLY. SO UNDER THIS
BILL THIS BUDGET BILL THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW I
KNOW IT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN BUT
UNDER THIS BUDGET BILL RIGHT
NOW RETROACTIVELY DATING THIS
TO JANUARY FIRST. AND THOSE
EMPLOYERS WHO DID NOT COMPLY
WITH PAYING EMPLOYEES- BECAUSE
IT WAS NOT REQUIRED BY LAW. TO
PAY THE EIGHTY HOURS A SICKLY
FOR SOMEONE SEEKING ASSISTANCE
FOR COVERT RELIEF FOR COVERT
SYMPTOMS ARE CARING FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER. WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO PAGA LAWSUITS AND WAGE THEFT
VIOLATIONS FOR NOT PAYING THEM
FOR A BILL THAT DID NOT EXIST
UNTIL WE PASSED THIS BILL. SO
THAT RETROACTIVITY BACK TO
JANUARY FIRST EXTREMELY
CONCERNS ME AND I'D LIKE
SOMEONE TO ADDRESS THAT PLEASE.
BERMAN FINANCE CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT. YES GOOD MORNING CHRIS
COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WOULD NOT BE IN VIOLATION
OF ANY PAGO LAW- GIVEN THAT IT
WILL BE RETROACTIVE THE
EMPLOYER STILL HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO PAY FOR AND
CORRECTS- TO ADDRESS THOSE-
DOES BY RETROACTIVE PAYMENTS-
PRIOR TO THE- FIRE TO THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THIS BILL SO
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THAT ACTION IT'S ONLY
IF THAT EMPLOYER CHOOSES TO NOT
ADDRESS THAT ACTION- THAT. THEY
WOULD BE IN VIOLATION. WOULD
YOU MIND. TELLING ME WHERETHAT'S IN THE BILL I HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE BILL I CAN'T FIND
THAT LANGUAGE ANYWHERE THAT
SAYS THAT EMPLOYERS WOULD NOT
BE PUNITIVE BE PUNISHED FOR
RETROACTIVELY PAIN THOSE
PAYMENTS- SO IF YOU COULD POINT
THAT OUT TO ME I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT I'M SORRY I
MISSED IT- YES- I BELIEVE THAT
SECTION- TO FORTY EIGHT. POINT
TWO LITTLE E. PARAGRAPH TWO
SUBPARAGRAPH C. OKAY AS I LOOK
FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
ANOTHER QUESTION- WILL THAT
ALSO COVERS THE INACCURATE WAIT%
STATEMENT FOR THE EMPLOYEE WAS
NOT AND PAID THE CORRECT WAGES
ON THEIR WEIGHT STATEMENT WHICH
CREATES IF A CIVIL PENALTY IN
A- IN A PENALTY FOR- WAGES AS
WELL FOR NOT HAVING AN ACCURATE
WAGE STATEMENTS ISSUED TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES. AND UNDER CURRENT
LAW AN EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE TO
RETROACTIVELY OBJECT EVERY PAGE
EVERY WAIT STATEMENT TO EVERY
EMPLOYEE AND RE MAIL THEM A
COPY OF AN ADJUSTED PAYSTUB
WITH THE CORRECT INFORMATION
SHOWING THE TWO WEEKS PAID. AND
THEN THEY WOULD HAVE TO MAIL
THAT WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD
DOES THAT STILL APPLY UNDER
THIS. SO I BELIEVE THERE'S A
PROVISION IN THERE THAT ALLOW
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE-
THOSE PAY STATEMENTS- FOR
EMPLOYERS I DON'T HAVE THE
CITATION ON HAND- BUT DEUCE BUT
DO NOTE THAT- THAT THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THERE THAT
PROFILES PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR EMPLOYERS TO
ADDRESS THOSE PAY STATEMENTS.
OKAY M. JUST ANOTHER QUESTION
ON THE FOLLOW UP SO I AM
LOOKING FOR A STATUS CODE
SECTION THAT YOU JUST CITED AND
I CAN'T SEEM TO FIND IT CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT PAGE AND WHAT LINE
ITEM THAT IS ON YOUR BILL. IS
SIXTEEN PAGES I'M TRYING TO GO
THROUGH IT. RAPIDA I DON'T HAVE
THAT PAGE REFERENCE IN FRONT OF
ME. THE TECHNICIAN MINUTES TO
FIND IT. SURE I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP. I THINK I'M SENATOR
GROW HOW ABOUT WILL LET'S GO
WILL RETURN TO YOU WHILE HE
LOOKS FOR THE PAGE NUMBER OKAY
AND WE'LL GET SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS HAVE I
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION OKAY AND
WHAT IF THAT'S POSSIBLE IT'S
NOT RELATED TO THAT SPECIFIC
WORDING. IN THE PREVIOUS BILL
AND THE PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE
BILL M. IN A PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE BILL IT WAS EIGHTY HOURS
PER CALENDAR YEAR AND THIS IS
EIGHTY HOURS- BUT IT DOESN'T
SAY. IT'S NOT IS IT IT IN THE
PREVIOUS VERSION IT WAS
DEFINITELY IDENTIFIED THAT YOU
COULD ONLY USE THE EIGHTY HOURS
OF SICKLY FOR COVERT IN A ONE
TIME- IN ONE TIME LIKE FOURTEEN
DAYS WITH A TICKET FOR DAYS
THREE DAYS TWO DAYS WHATEVER TO
TAKE CAE OF A FAMILY MEMBER.
IT WAS A TOTAL OF FOURTEEN DAYS
OR EIGHTY HOURS. THIS BILL
DOESN'T MAKE IT A TOTAL OF
EIGHTY HOURS IN THE LANGUAGE
AND I REALIZE IT'S OVER IN
SEPTEMBER BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE A
TOTAL HOURS. IN THE LANGUAGE SO
I DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT AND
THEN GO BACK TO MY PREVIOUS
QUESTION- ON WHERE IT'S AT THE
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE
RETROACTIVITY AND THAT THE
PENALIZING OF EMPLOYERS I'D
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. YEAH
CHRIS COOK WITH FINANCE AGAIN
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT IT
DOES PROVIDE UP TO EIGHTY
HOURS- I DON'T THINK I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
IT NOT BEING- NOT ALLOWING FOR
EIGHTY HOURS. SO IT IT IT IT
SHOULD ALLOW FOR UP TO EIGHTY
HOURS THAT SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE. SO IT'S NOT UP TO
EIGHTY HOURS AND THAT WAS MY
QUESTION I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING AND MORE EXPLICIT- AND-
IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE
BILL. IT SAID IT WAS A- EIGHTY
HOURS MAXIMUM BASICALLY DIDN'T
USE THE WORD MAXIMUM I CAN PULL
IT OUT. OF EIGHTY HOURS IN A
CALENDAR YEAR THERE'S A
PREVIOUS VERSION. THIS IS
EIGHTY HOURS BUT IT DOESN'T SAY
MAXIMUM SO MY QUESTION IS WILL
DEPLOY YEARS. AND BE REQUIRED
TO PAY EIGHTY HOURS AND THEN
THIRTY DAYS LATER PAID. AND
ANOTHER TWO WEEKS OR TWO MONTHS
LATER BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER
FAMILY MEMBER THAT'S ILL PAY
ANOTHER TWO WEEKS. BECAUSE
THERE'S NO MAXIMUM IN THIS
VERSION OF THE BILL THAT I CAN
FIND AND AGAIN I JUST GOT THE
LANGUAGE I THINK IT WAS. LATE
SUNDAY NIGHT LAST NIGHT SO-
BECAUSE IT I THINK IT WENT IN
FRIDAY AND WAS AMENDED ON
SATURDAY AND I GOT IT SUNDAY-
SO I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
COMPLETELY DIGEST EACH LABOR
CODE BUT IF YOU WOULD JUST
POINT THAT OUT TO ME SO I CAN
BE SURE. THAT EMPLOYERS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE. REQUIRED TO PAY
MULTIPLE FOURTEEN DAY PERIODS
OR MULTIPLE TIME FRAMES. AND
THEN ALSO THE RETROACTIVITY
ISSUE THAT I ADDRESSED EARLIER
TELL ME THE CODE SECTION. AND I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SCENE-
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING. BUT IN
THE REAL WORLD EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE CAN'T OPERATE ON YOUR
UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE TO
OPERATE ON THE EXACT LANGUAGE.
THAT IS IN THIS BILL AND I'D
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU COULD
JUST- COVER THE SUBJECT MATTERS
FOR ME. THANK YOU. RIGHT SO
AGAIN CHRIS WITH FINANCE- NO IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY HOURS IT'S ONLY EIGHTY
HOURS A SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR THE CALENDAR YEAR. SO
FROM JANUARY TO SEPTEMBER
EIGHTY HOURS TOTAL. AGAIN CAN
YOU SHOW ME WHERE THAT IS IN
THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT WAS IN
THE PREVIOUS VERSION BUT I
CAN'T FIND IT IN THIS VERSION.
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
REFERENCE I HAVE TO GO BACK AND
LOOK. AT THE CODE SECTION TO
FIND EXACTLY WHAT SECTION THAT
IS REFERENCING. OKAY THANK YOU.
IF DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REFINES THE CODE SECTION WE CAN
RETURN. LET SARAH KEEP GOING
WITH OUR- QUESTIONS REMEMBER
SENATOR DRAWS ARE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I PARTIALLY IS
LIKE A COMMENT ON THE QUESTION-
OBVIOUSLY IT WON'T APPLY THE
ACTION FOR. THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
COVERED I THINK THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO. BE PART OF SOLVING
AND STOPPING THE SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN- IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US AND HAVING THE
ABILITY TO TAKE THE TIME AND
NOT WORRY ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE PAY. IS PART
OF THE DECISION THAT A WORKING
PERSON MAKES ARE TO TAKE THE
TIME OFF TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
THAT'S GOOD FOR ALL OF US AND
SO I THINK IT'S- REALLY GOOD
THAT WE'RE TAKING THAT ONE-
ACTION. HOWEVER I. LARGE
EXEMPTION OF THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYERS WHO WILL HAVE WHICH
IS UNDER TWENTY FIVE. EMPLOYEES
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THAT'S UP TO FOUR MILLION
WORKERS THAT WOULD BE EXEMPT
FROM THE PAID SICK LEAVE UNDER
THE THRESHOLD OF THIS BILL-
SMALL BUSINESSES. ARE GETTING A
LOT OF ASSISTANCE AND I'VE
SUPPORTED THAT VERY ACTIVELY-
WE RECENTLY OF FUNDED TWO POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS ON TOP OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE HAD PROVIDED.
EARLIER RELIEF I SUPPORT THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK FOR
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES. TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE TIME THAT.
THEY NEED- AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THIS- THEY USUALLY
ALL ARE OF LOW WAGE WORKERS-
WITH EXCEPTIONS OF COURSE-
THERE ARE- COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WORKERS THEIR- FRONTLINE
WORKERS AND TO EXCLUDE THEM.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE ANY PUBLIC
HEALTH SENSE TO ME- SO I.
ALWAYS MAKING THAT COMMENT
WITH- GREAT CONCERN OVER THOSE-
MILLIONS OF MEN AND WOMEN- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHAT WAS
THE RATIONALE AND WIDE TO THE
CUT OFF FOR THE THRESHOLD AT-
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR- THE
TWENTY FIVE OR BELOW THE
THRESHOLD WAS WAS REALLY TO
STRIKE A BALANCE- PROVIDING
SICK LEAVE FOR- SMALL
BUSINESSES SMALL NOT IMPOSING
ANY ADDITIONAL HARDSHIPS AND I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT YOU KNOW
AS YOU'VE NOTED- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF-
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO SMALL
BUSINESSES I THINK YOU IN THE
CHAIR BOTH NOTED THE TWO POINT
ONE BILLION. FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS- IN ADDITION
YOU KNOW THERE IS THAT FEDERAL-
LAW DOES STATE THAT THIS IS
STILL OPTIONAL AND SO- IF THEY
SO CHOOSE WHICH OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO DO SO- TO
PROVIDE THIS SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT- THAT. VERY GENEROUS I
TAX CREDIT THAT THEY CANNOT
RECEIVE. LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS YES- SENATOR MAN
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU- HAVE
TAKEN PHYSICISTS I'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT THIS BILL I FOLLOWED
IT. LOSI IT'S BEEN A TOUGH ONE
FOR ME BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF BUSINESSES
PARTICULARLY SMALL BUSINESSES
IN MY COMMUNITY. BETTER REALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW- YOU KNOW
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
CLOSED. IT IS OBVIOUSLY TOUGH
ECONOMIC TIMES BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND THERE ARE ALSO MANY MANY
WORKERS THAT ARE BARELY GETTING
BY AS WELL. AND THE LAST THING
WE WANT WORKERS TO BE WORRYING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS MISSING
PAYCHECKS PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE- OR POTENTIALLY LOSING
THEIR JOBS. BECAUSE THEY GOT
SICK WOULD COVER NINETEEN
WHETHER ON THE JOB OR ELSEWHERE-
WE HAVE ISSUES OF ECONOMIC
FAIRNESS AS MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR ALSO POINTED OUT. MANY
OF THESE WORKERS ARE LOW WAGE
THERE PEOPLE OF COLOR- THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK
WITH COVERT COMING INTO WORK-
SO I KNOW A LOT OF HARD WORK
WENT INTO THIS. I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION IS JUST- YOU
KNOW I. AM I THINK HAPPY WITH
THE OUTCOME I BELIEVE THAT WITH
THE- DIFFERENT. ACTIONS THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATURES TAKEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
TAKING. THESE BUSINESSES ARE
GETTING A LOT OF RELIEF- TO
HELP COVER. SOME OF THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS BUT- I'D
BE CURIOUS IF- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MIGHT ELABORATE- TO
WHAT DEGREE WILL THIS ALL BE
COVERED UNDER FEDERAL AND
STATE. PROGRAMS AND FUNDING.
THE PURPOSE I NEED TO GO AHEAD
I THINK YOU SHOULD EXPLAIN THE-
FACT THAT THESE TAX CREDITS
BASICALLY COVER THE EMPLOYERS
COSTS BUT GO AHEAD. YES
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU TERRY-
SENTIMENT YES THE SMALL
BUSINESSES- IF THEY SO CHOOSE
TO PROVIDED BELOW TWENTY FIVE
IN OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THE SMALL
BUSINESSES OVER THAT. THEY DO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THIS AND GET A PRETTY GENEROUS
CREDIT- FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS A ONE TO
ONE- SO. THAT FEDERAL LAW DOES
COMPENSATE THEM FOR THIS LEAVE
THAT IS TAKEN AND ONE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADD IS. IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT MANY LOW LOCALS ARE ALSO
PROVIDING OUR HAVE EXTENDED THE
BASICALLY THAT WAS- ENACTED
EARLIER THIS YEAR UNDER AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN- I BELIEVE
L. A. SAN JOSE OAKLAND- TO NAME
A FEW- THIS THIS LEGISLATION
REALLY PROVIDES- SENT
STATEWIDE- GARDENS AND- CLARITY.
THIS IS THE SHOULD BE APPLIED
UNIFORMLY ACROSS THE STATE SO-
AGAIN MANY LOCALS HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
PROVIDE THE SICKLY EVEN THIS IS
JUST PROVIDING THAT UNIFORM
GUIDANCE GOT STATE. AND
SUGGESTED THAT I HEARD
CORRECTLY COVERS ONE TO ONE SO
THERE IS NO HARM TO BUSINESSES
THAT PROVIDE THIS SICK LEAVE.
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC I
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE- I HAD
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION I
THINK WE'RE SO CLOSE TO SEEING
THE END OF THIS. PANDEMIC AND
THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT HIS
COMPANY TO. BUT ONE OF THE KEYS
IS GOING TO BE VACCINATIONS AND
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT VACCINATION
ROLLOUT. ONE CONCERN I HAVE IS
AROUND TAKE UP AND THOSE WHO
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT NOT BE
WILLING FOR SOME REASON TO TAKE
THE VACCINE- IN I GUESS I'D I
KNOW I KNOW THIS BILL HAS BEEN.
HARD COPY THE HARD NEGOTIATED
AND IT'S IN A LATE POINT AND SO
I DON'T. WANT TO PUSH
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT
THINGS GOING FORWARD- IT WOULD
HAVE STRUCK ME AS A GOOD IDEA
TO CONSIDER REQUIRING
VACCINATIONS FOR ANY EMPLOYEE
OR WORKER THAT- OR AN EXCUSE IF
THEY WANT TO OPT OUT BUT BUT
SOME. VALID REASON FOR A WORKER-TO NOT GET VACCINATED BECAUSE I
THINK WE NEED TO BE ENCOURAGING
VACCINATIONS THAT'S GONNA BE
KEY FOR US GETTING OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER A- DR PAN SENATOR SAM
YES THANK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AND AGAIN- FREESHEET THE
WORK THAT WENT INTO THIS BILL
AND CERTAINLY FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDPOINT ONE BE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE CODE WHICH IS
A CONTAGIOUS DISEASE ARE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY- ISOLATE. IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO SIMPLY TEST PEOPLE
AND- EVEN CONTACT TRACE THEM TO
FIND OUT WHETHER THEY EXPOSED
BUT ALSO IF THEY'VE BEEN
EXPOSED OR SYMPTOMATIC OR- ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC AND TRYING TO
FIRESTEEL STAY HOME SO- TO HELP
PREVENT FURTHER SPREAD OF THIS
DISEASE WHICH ALSO IF IT
CONTINUES TO SPREAD. NOW AS IT
SPREAD CERTAINLY- THEN
DISCOURAGES PEOPLEFROM BEING
ABLE TO DO WORK OR- SHOPPER DO
WHATEVER OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO HELP SUPPORT
BUSINESS. I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT- HI IN RELATION TO NOT
ONLY FOR WHAT WOULD BE ON SO WE
BASICALLY BUDGET A HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR- STAFFING RESOURCE
LABOR COMMISSIONER WHICH MAKES
SENSE BUT- TO WHAT DEGREE ARE
WE ACTUALLY INFORMING SMALL
BUSINESSES THEMSELVES- THAT
EIGHT. OF THE SPECIFICS OF NOT
ONLY THIS BILL BUT ALSO OF OUR
PREVIOUS ACTIONS EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND- THE WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DOING
BECAUSE- I MEAN I DO HEARINGS
ARE YOU FROM SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES IT'S
BECAUSE THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE- ACTED INFORMATION AND
YOUR EMPLOYER. THE THINGS THAT
YOU NEED TO DO TO GET YOUR TAX
CREDITS OVER THE VEIL ABILITY
SOMETIMES- PEOPLE MAY NOT BE AS
AWARE AS WHEN I THINK THEY ARE
HERE YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT SPENDING THE YOU
KNOW THIS MORNING DISCUSSING
THIS BILL AND- AND THE
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT- WITH
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE OUT
THERE TRYING TO RUN YOUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE NOT MISLEADING
ATTENTION WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE OTHERS IN THIS ROOM ARE.
ARE SOMEWHERE ELSE SO WHAT ARE
WE DOING IN TERMS OF. GETTING
INFORMATION OUT TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS MANY OF WHOM
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE SMALLER
BUSINESS. YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET
HR UPDATES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO JUST RUN YOUR
BUSINESS AND- AS OF ANYTHING
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN WHAT'S
NORMAL WHICH IS EVEN CREE COVE
IN TERMS OF HOW- WHAT KIND OF
TAX CREDITS AND THINGS TO GET
YOU MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE THAT
AWARE OF. SO ARE WE DOING TO
EDUCATE SMALL BUSINESS CENTER
SO THEY THEY KNOW THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROVIDE THEM
THE KIND OF SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO DO THAT. AND AND SO THEY'RE
NOT SO ANXIOUS ABOUT. THESE
REQUIREMENTS THAT- THAT WE'RE
NOT. DOING AND IF THEY KNOW
THAT THERE'S HELP AVAILABLE.
BERMAN FOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT. YEAH I I'D HAVE
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU FOR
QUESTION I I'D HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE SPECIFIC- OUT
REACH EFFORTS THAT- THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE MAY BE
PROVIDING BY I DO KNOW THAT
THEY THEY PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH FAN CLUB
AND- YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL-
SPECIFICS ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE AS THEY DID
WITH AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN-
SO I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THAT
WOULD BE SIMILAR SIMILARLY THE
CASE WITH THIS- LEGISLATION AS
WELL THAT HE PROVIDING GUIDANCE
ON THE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS-
BUSINESSES NEED TO COMPLY WITH
ACCESS I POINT OUT THAT MY
FAMILY WERE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER
WHEN I'VE GOTTEN A NOTICE. AND
I KNOW BECAUSE I'M HERE. SO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO BE VERY
PROACTIVE ABOUT THAT AND IN
SOME SENSES A WONDER YOU KNOW
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE A LARGER
BUDGET ITEM TO TRY TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO YOU SO FOR
EXAMPLE IS EDT SENDING A NOTICE
TO EVERY EMPLOYER. THAT SAYING
WITH A SHEET THAT SAYS THIS IS
WHAT- IF YOU HAVE A PAYROLL
COMPANY IS THERE A DAY SENDING
A DAY ASKING THEM TO SEND OUT A
GUIDANCE SHE TO SAY THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT YOU CAN AVAIL
YOURSELF OF NOW HERE'S- INDOOR
TO GET SUPPORT- AND
NOTIFICATION OF THAT. SORT SO I
THINK SOME MORE SPECIFICS WOULD
BE HELPFUL BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO AND I SEE AND-
AGAIN PROCEED ALL THE WORK
THAT'S GOING INTO THIS BUT IF.
ON THE FRONT LINES FOR MANAGING
PAYROLLS. THE CUTTING PAYROLL
CHECKS DON'T KNOW THEN THAT'S
WHERE WE GET PROBLEMS RIGHT
BECAUSE WE WANT THEM TO GIVE
THE LEAVES WE WANT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO BALANCE OUR BOOKS AND
WHAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE HELP
IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN
THEIR VAN YOU KNOW THEN THAT
DAY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE KIND ARE
CAUGHT BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE TO BE I THINK WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
EDUCATING THEM. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE BEFORE YOU RESPOND.
SO THE E. TAX CREDITS FOR THIS
PAID SICK LEAVE. THAT WE ARE IN
EFFECT EXTENDING NOW. WERE IN
EFFECT SINCE THE FIRST FEDERAL
CARE SECTORS THAT CORRECT. THE
TAX CREDIT WAS IMPLEMENTED
UNDER THE FAMILY FIRST
ACROBATICS RELIEF ACT SO. WHAT
NINE WHICH WHICH TIME IN TWENTY
TWENTY- I BELIEVE FAMILY FIRST
WAS ENACTED OUR EARLY ON I
WANNA SAY AROUND MARCH AND
APRIL SO IN OTHER WORDS
EMPLOYERS. HAVE AND PAYCHECK
COMPANIES BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THESE PROVISIONS WERE IN
EFFECT STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY. WELL ALL OF THEM DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY DO AS RESULT AND
NOT MINIMIZING THAT IT'S
BENEFICIAL TO INFORM THEM I'M
JUST POINTING OUT THAT THIS IS
NOT- WE'RE WE'RE NOT CREATING A
WHOLLY NEW PROVISION. SOME
SENATOR PAN MANAGER AT EVERY
SEAT THAT AND I DO UNDERSTAND I
DO THINK THAT ESPECIALLY THE
SMALLER TO BUSINESS AND YOU
KNOW WERE I REALIZE THAT WE
HAVE A CUT OFF YOUR FOR TWENTY
FIVE AND UNDER WHICH I KNOW
THAT- SOME PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT- WE ALSO WANT TO CURSE
THEM THE SMALLER THE COMPANY
YOU ARE THE LESS LIKELY SO NO
ONE'S WITH HR DEPARTMENTS
REACTION OF A PERSON IS
ASSIGNED TO DO THAT IF YOU
ESSENTIALLY IT'S THE OWNER. OR
ONE OF THEIR SENIOR STAFF IS
DOING HR AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION THEY'RE GETTING- SO
IT EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR A LITTLE WHILE- AND THIS IS
MORE EXTENSION SO I REALIZE I'M
RAISING THIS IN RELATION TO
THIS BILL FOR SOMETHING THAT
WERE. TRYING TO EXTEND. I THINK
WE COULD PERHAPS DO A BETTER
JOB IN TRYING TO COMMUNICATE
THAT TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
TO- UNFORTUNATELY MAY NOT BE IS
AWARE THAT. THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
HEALTH AND TRYING TO PROVIDE
SICK LEAVE SITE FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES- SO. I AM JUST
THINKING HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
SOME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S BEEN DONE TO COMMUNICATE
TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
PERHAPS. THROUGH ETFS OR
THROUGH- EASY FOR ANYONE WHO
ACTUALLY HAS THE FILE PAYROLL
REPORTS WHAT KIND OF
NOTIFICATIONS THEY'VE BEEN SENT
DIRECTLY. ABOUT TO TEXAS HELP
THEY CAN GET NOW PROVIDING. A
SICKLY. CENTERVILLE'S THEN
SENATOR MULLIN. A MADAM CHAIR
AS I THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
CONCERNED INACTIVE GET ON THE
RECORD. THE MAJORITY STAFF WAS
VERY HELPFUL WITH THE MINORITY
STAFF TO GETTING THE
INFORMATION OF THE AMENDMENTS
SO THAT WE COULD ANALYZE AND TO
THE MEMBERS. ARE UPDATED
PROPERLY. BUT THERE ARE-
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEY PROBABLY HAVE
THOUSANDS THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS. AND
THAT THIS HAPPENED OVER THE
WEEKEND I WOULD ARGUE AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT WHICH PERSON.
PURPOSEFUL BUT THAT IT.
PRECLUDED THEM FROM THE NAY
OPPORTUNITY RIGHTEOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
LANGUAGE. WHATEVER THE
AMENDMENTS ARE AND HOW IT WOULD
HAVE IMPACTED THEM INDIVIDUALLY.
SO I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
INJUSTICE FOR SOMETHING OF THIS
MAGNITUDE AND I LIST A LIKE TO
LIKE LIVE CHAT IS A CONCERN ON
THE RECORD. CERTAINLY I- THERE
WAS A REFERENCE BEFORE THAT
THIS A- WAS NOT OPEN UNTIL THE
WEEKEND IN FACT I MEAN IF
YOU'RE CONCERNS MAY STILL- BE
THERE HOWEVER IT WAS IN FRENCH
FOUR PM FRIDAY JUST JUST
CLARIFYING WHEN THE BILL WAS IN
PRINT. CENTER MELINDA'S. M.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST AM
CURIOUS ABOUT THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IN
ORDER TO ENFORCE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL AND HOW THAT NUMBER
WAS ARRIVED UPON BECAUSE WINDER
STAND THAT THESE TYPES OF BILL
MUST HAVE A BUDGET
APPROPRIATION AND THEM THIS
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS- A
SEEMS A LITTLE RANDOM A AND B.
I DON'T KNOW I'M JUST AND- IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE- IT WOULD
EVEN BE ENOUGH IF THEY REALLY
WANNA. GO OUT AND FORCES SO CAN
SOMEONE ANSWER PLEASE HOW A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
THE NUMBER THAT WAS LANDED UPON.
BERMAN FINANCE. YES SENATOR A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A
ROUGH ESTIMATE OF APPROXIMATELY
ONE STAFFER IDEA HARD TO HELP
COORDINATE AND TO- YOU KNOW
AND- HELP YOU KNOW AS KNOW SOME
OF THESE- THESE WERE FORCE-
THESE WORKLOAD- KANNST SO
REALLY IT'S JUST ONE ADDITION
STAFF HELP YOU- KEEP- TELL THE
DRESS SOMEBODY'S CONCERN AS
THEIR IN IN. CAN ROUTE THEM TO
THE STAFF D. A. R. OKAY THING
YOU SO- YOU YOU WOULD BE HIRING
AN ADDITIONAL PERSON TO OVERSEE
THIS EFFORT OR- SOMEBODY
ALREADY HAVE. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. I'D HAVE TO DEFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
SPECIFICS OF THE HIRING BY A
WOULD IT BE ONE PERSON WHETHER
THAT'S- SOMEONE THAT'S BEING
REDIRECTED INTERNAL OR NEW HIRE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU WHAT C.
ADDITIONAL QUESTION SENATOR
GROW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
BECAUSE I MAY HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES RESPOND TO MY
COLLEAGUE AT IRVINE MY
UNDERSTANDING WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RESPOND-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT IS A
IT WAS A ONE TO ONE
REIMBURSEMENT- DID I HEAR THAT
CORRECTLY TAX CREDIT. BERMAN
FINANCE GO AHEAD. YES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDES A
ONE TO ONE TAX CREDIT. FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO. UTILIZE
THE ELIGIBLE BUSINESSES WHO USE
THE SUPPLEMENTAL BASICALLY.
OKAY WELL THAT SAID I'M NOT THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
PLAN CLEARLY SAYS THAT THERE'S
A TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR A DAY CAP
IN SOME CASES AND DEPENDING ON
WHICH IS A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP IN OTHERS. SO ANYBODY OVER
MAKING TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR WOULD NOT BE A ONE TO
ONE REIMBURSEMENT BASED ON THE
FEDERAL PLANNED IT THAT WAS
JUST SIGNED BY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. IS THAT NOT
CORRECT IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT HAVE A CAP.
YES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
AS A CAP IS FIVE HUNDRED AND
TEN DOLLARS A DAY AND A MAXIMUM
OF. FIVE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN DOLLARS. CAP SO IF AN
EMPLOYER PAYS AN EMPLOYEE OVER
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
EVEN IF THEY ARE SMALL BUSINESS
THERE WOULD NOT BE A ONE TO ONE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
TAX CREDITS IS THAT CLEAR IS
THAT CORRECT IT WOULD BE A ONE
TO ONE MATCH UP TO THE CAP TO
THE CAP OKAY I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTOOD- AND DID
A FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTION FROM IRVINE. THANK YOU.
SEPTIC CERTAINLY. ALL RIGHT LET
ME SEE. OKAY I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GO SENATOR MELENDEZ.
SENATOR MELENDEZ GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR ON WHAT WAS
JUST STATED SO IT'S A ONE TO
ONE MATCH UP TO THE CAP WHICH
MEANS. THAT'S THIRDS UP TO TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE UP TO. FIVE
HUNDRED ELEVEN HUNDRED BERMAN
FINANCED YOU WANNA DRESS THAT.
YES FIVE THE CAP IS FIVE
HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS A DAY.
FIVE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE- IN TOTALITY AND I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE IN ADDITION TO
THE MATCH WITH THE CAT THE
FEDERAL CAP OR THAT TAX CREDIT
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL I WOULD
JUST REITERATE THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS ALSO IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL
SMALL BUSINESS PACKAGES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES PROVIDE RELIEF
INCLUDING THE TWO POINT ONE
BILLION FOR. THOSE GRANTS IN
ADDITION TO THE DEAL THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS FOR-
THE PAYCHECK PROTECT PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM SO IN
ADDITION TO THAT TAX CREDIT
ALTHOUGH IT DOES HAVE A CAP
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO PROVIDING
SMALL BUSINESSES MANY
RESOURCES. ALLEVIATE THE
PRESSURES OF CODE. OKAY SO
THANK YOU I JUST I THINK
THERE'S SOME DISCREPANCY HERE
AS TO WHAT THE CAP WAS IN WHAT
IS- WHAT WE'RE BEING TOLD HERE
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S-
OUT AND- NOT GOING TO COVER ALL
THE COSTS IN- IN MANY CASES.
SO- THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
FIVE WHY DON'T WE NOW SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS OF A BILL.
ANYONE IN THIS HEARING ROOM
SEEING NINE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OUR OF A. AUXILIARY ROOM SEEING
NINE- THE MODERATOR CAN YOU
QUEUE UP THE PHONE LINES TO SEE
WHETHER THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND THAT PHONE LINE NUMBER
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. WITH
THE- YOU'RE RIGHT I WAS WAITING
UNTIL THE LAST BILL
PRESENTATION APOLOGIES I'M SO
USED TO JUST GETTING TO-
TESTIMONY RIGHT AFTER THE BILL
SO YOU'RE RIGHT I'M GOING TO.
GET ON TO OUR FLOOR THE
DISCUSSION ON THE NEXT BILL BUT
BEFORE YOU DO WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT ABOUT THIS- PAIDSICK
LEAVE- WELL I APPRECIATE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES-
EXPRESSIONS OF CONCERN. I THINK
THAT ALL OF US SHOULD BE MORE
CONCERNED IF EMPLOYEES SHOW UP
AT WORK WITH KOBE. WE ARE
TRYING TO STOP THIS PANDEMIC
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO CONTAIN
THE SPREAD IF PEOPLE ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES ONE OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDELINES TELL US. THEY
TELL US IF. WE SUSPECT WE HAVE
CODED. TO STAY HOME. I DO NOT
WANT TO GET CODED I DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE PEOPLE GOING OUT TO
WORK. THE ONLY WAY MANY MANY
PEOPLE CAN AVOID GOING TO WORK
IS IF THEY DO NOT LOSE THEIR
PAYCHECK SO I AM HIGHLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. MAKING THIS
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE. AND
AS THEY DID LAST YEAR. AND I
THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO GO TO
SEPTEMBER BECAUSE I AM
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE WILL HAVE.
THIS PANDEMIC CONTAIN BY THEN
BUT WE WILL NOT IF PEOPLE. DEFY
DO DO NOT FOLLOW THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE THAT WAS GIVEN.
IF PEOPLE EITHER ARE NOT
VACCINATED OR ARE OUT AND ABOUT
IN WORKING WITH KOBE. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE A PANDEMIC. ON
OUR HANDS WHICH WE ARE ALL.
DESK TO CONTAIN SO I GREET
APPRECIATE THIS AND I HOPE THAT
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES WHILE
WE'RE NOT MANDATING THEM TO DO
SO WITH THIS BILL I HOPE THAT
THEY WILL MAKE IT AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE AS I INDICATED WE DO
NOT WANT PEOPLE GOING TO WORK
WELCOME. NOW LET US GO TO THE
NEXT BILL. WHICH IS- ONE MOMENT.
I'M GETTING THERE- AB EIGHTY
EIGHT THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
CLEANUP DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE PERCENT. GREAT AB EIGHTY
EIGHT AMENDS SB EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW ON
FEBRUARY AND PROVIDES A ONE
TIME STIMULUS PAYMENT OF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO QUALIFIED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT AND FOR INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
HOUSEHOLDS THAT MADE LESS THAN
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN A JOKE ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME
FOR TAX YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. SB
EIGHTY EIGHT ALSO PROVIDES A
ONE TIME SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
SUPPLEMENTAL PICK GRANT PAYMENT
THE HOUSEHOLDS ENROLLED IN THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND
RECIPIENTS OF SS I SS P. AND
CASH ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
IMMIGRANTS AB EIGHTY EIGHT
CLARIFIES THE GRANT PAYMENTS
ARE EXEMPT FROM STATE TAXATION
EXEMPTS GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
AND GRANT PAYMENTS FROM
GARNISHMENT ORDERS EXCEPT FOR
CHILD SUPPORT SPOUSAL SUPPORT
FAMILY SUPPORT OR CRIMINAL
RESTITUTION PAID. PAYABLE TO
VICTIMS' AND LASTLY CLARIFIES
THE DEFINITION OF GRANT
RECIPIENT AND INCLUDES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TIED TO
AUTOMATION I AM JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE JENNIFER LOPEZ. AND
J. CHAMBERLAIN FOR QUESTIONS.
WHAT'S GOING TO TURN ON THE
MARK ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THIS CLEAN UP TO THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS. SEEING
THOUGH MIKE'S UP THERE TO SEE
ANY. NO ALL RIGHT- THEN I THINK
WE ARE NOW READY TO GO TO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT. SO WE HAVE IT
WE ARE NOW OPENING IT UP TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THESE
THREE BILLS THAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH. AND LET ME SEE FIRST IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OUR- IN THE
CURRENT IN THIS HEARING ROOM
WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY ON ANY OF
THESE BILLS IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NINE AND SEEING NO ONE IN THE
OVERFLOW. THEN MODERATOR DID
YOU SAY HE UP THE PHONE LINES
AS I INDICATED BEFORE THE PHONE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SIX ONE
ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE. OR A
MURDER THIS IS IN SUPPORT WILL
DO OPPOSITION AFTER. MODERATOR.
MODERATOR WHO IS HANDLING THE
TELEPHONE LINES I HAVE NOW
PROMPTED THAT WE ARE TAKING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I HAVE
READ THE PHONE NUMBER AND THE
ACCESS CODE COULD YOU PLEASE T.
UP. ANY A PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND THIS IS ON
ANY OF THE THREE BILLS THAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH. WHICH ARE S.
B. EIGHTY OUR EXCUSE ME AB
EIGHTY THREE AB EIGHTY FOUR IN
AB EIGHTY EIGHT. MARTIN I HAVE
A LOT OF ANY COMMENTS IN Q. A-
POLOTA LIGHTED SEVENTEEN COULD.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL TRY LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I AM NOT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT I AM IN OPPOSITION
IS IT OKAY IF I GO AHEAD AND
SPEAK NOW. GO AHEAD. BUT POLICE
MODERATOR DANGER HERE THAT WE
HAVE ONLY THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT NOW TAKE OPPOSITION
LATER BUT GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM BARBARA
COLLEGIATE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. OUR
POSITION ON EIGHTY EIGHTY POOR
IT'S SUPPOSED TO LIVE FROM
NANDED. THE AMENDMENT THAT WE
REQUESTED WERE TO ENSURE THAT
HOSPITALS COULD BALANCE THE
FLEET POLICIES WITH THE ABILITY
OF OUR HOSPITAL TO CONTINUE TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS DURING THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC. WHICH ALSO
SHARES MANY OF THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I'M SURE YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM LATER. FOR THESE
REASONS WE WOULD REQUEST YOU
VOTE NO ON AB EIGHTY FOUR WHEN
THE BILL. COMES BEFORE YOU
THANK YOU. MODERATOR GO AHEAD
P. IN SOME PLEASE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO YOU MAY REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM THIS QUEUE BY
REPEATING THE ONE ZERO COMMANDS
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING EACH TEAM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRS THAT BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. URGING
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE PAID SICK
LEAVE PROPOSAL SB EIGHTY FOUR A
QUICK PERSONAL ANECDOTE MY
HOUSEHOLD. CONTRACTED COATED
NINETEEN AND CAME OUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE THANKFULLY I'M LUCKY
TO BE ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME
BUT MY WIFE WORKS IN THE
PAYROLL OFFICE AT THE OAK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WORKERS NEED THE PAYCHECK EVEN
DURING THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC SO
SHE MUST REPORT TO WORK WHEN
THE FIRST MEMBER OF OUR
HOUSEHOLD MY DAUGHTER TESTED
POSITIVE IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR. MY WIFE WAS QUARANTINED
AND SPENT A WEEK TAKING CARE OF
HER BEFORE TESTING POSITIVE
HERSELF. NOT LEAVE THAT SHE
TOOK DURING THE TWO QUARANTINES
TOTALLY WIPED OUT HER THREE
LEAD. AND SHE WONDERS WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IF YOU GET SICK.
STAYING HOME GREATLY LIMITED
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS OUTSIDE
OF OUR HOUSEHOLD BUT THIS BILL
ACKNOWLEDGES THE IMPACT OF THIS
WIDESPREAD PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY FUND FAMILIES LIKE
MINE. AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF FOR ALL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BLIND THREE LITTLE OR NO
PLEASE. SORRY HELLO THIS IS J.
ON OF THAT YEAH YOU- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE E. EIGHTY
FOUR- WE THINK ALL WORKERS MUST
HAVE ACCESS TO EIGHT SICK LEAVE
IT IS A VITAL PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE- AND- WE THINK IT IS-
WE URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE YES. ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
REBECCA COUSINS AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER FOR CALIFORNIA ARE WE
SUPPORT AB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR. BOB BECAUSE
WE SUPPORT THE FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA. NEED PAID SICK
LEAVE SO THEY CAN HELP TO KEEP
THEIR OLDER LOVED ONES OUT OF
HOSPITALS AND NURSING HOMES SO
PLEASE VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS KATIE
WATER SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE
ARE CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT AB EIGHTY FOUR AND IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT EMERGENCY
KIT SIX DAYS BILL WILL SAVE
LIVES ALL OVER CALIFORNIA AND
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR MEMBERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION UNITE
HERE UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA THE MACHINISTS UNION
AND IFTTT LOCALS TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU READY
FOR IT. GO AHEAD I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT FOURTEENTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARIA MORENO I'M A RESTAURANT
WORKERS FROM FRANCISCO AND ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE ORGANIZATION OF
RUSSIAN OPPORTUNITY CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
RESTAURANT WORKERS AROUND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY FOUR. WE'VE HEARD
STORIES OF RESTAURANT WORKERS
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ACCESSING- YOU THINK I'M LAST
YEAR AND THE PLACES WHERE THEY
HAVE IT AND IT HAD BEEN
INFINITELY. USEFUL AND
ESSENTIAL FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES
DURING THIS TIME- PLEASE PLEASE
PLEASE- EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY VALVE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE V. EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT'S REALLY
THE LEAST WE CAN DO FOR THESE
WORKERS HAVE BEEN DOING SO MUCH
TO KEEP CALIFORNIA FUNCTIONING
DURING THE PANDEMIC MOST OF
THEM ARE NOT VACCINATED AND
SOME OF THEM WILL BE VACCINATED
FOR WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS. AND SO
IN ADDITION TO THEM HAVING TO
WORK THROUGH THEIR ILLNESS IF
THEY DO GET IT IT WILL IN MANY
CASES THE HORSE TO COME TO WORK
WHILE CHECK SPREADING THE VIRUS
TO CO WORKERS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND DOING DIRECT
TARGET TO OUR COLLECTIVE EFFORT
TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. IN ADDITION ALL THE
OTHER REASONS STATED WE
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT THE STOCK.
THANK YOU RYAN SIXTEEN PLEASE
CALL APPLE. THANK YOU GUYS HEAR
ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS AN OCCASION TO CALL
RIGHT ON THE BALLOT WORK THANKS
AND I JUST WANT TO COMMUNICATE
THAT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY FOR THE PAID SICK
LEAVE BILL WHAT OTHER THING
MANDATE A LOT OF WORKERS WON'T
HAVE THE SAFETY NETS RELY ON
THE DAY ARE BOTH TO WORK WITH
KOBE AND I WILL BE. GOING TO
WORK IN BRING THE VIRUS AND
ADDS BRANDENBURGIAN ARE YOU
COMMUNICATED THAT WOULD HELP
CURB THE PANDEMIC STYLE BUT
THAT KIND OF REQUEST THAT
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ACTED
IMMEDIATELY TO PROTECT THE
WORKERS AND. THE PUBLIC COMPANY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WRITER FOUR CALL. HI
MY NAME IS THE PALMER I'M A
MOTHER AND CARE GIVER AND RUN A
SMALL NONPROFIT WITH BY SIMPLY
COOK RECIPE DELAY ON A
CONSTITUENT OF THE SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTY
FOUR BECAUSE WE NEED SACRAMENTO
PAPERCLIPS AND STOP THE SPREAD
OF COULD BE NINETEEN. ONE OF MY
EMPLOYEES WITH THAT BUT PEOPLE
THAT SHE'S A SINGLE MOM OF
THREE CHILDREN WITH ADDITIONAL
NEEDS THANK YOU SHE RECEIVED
LAST YEAR HUGHES WHAT WITHOUT
THAT HE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CARE FOR HERSELF AND
HER FAMILY AND BECAUSE I WAS
ABLE TO GIVE HER THAT KIND. SHE
WAS MORE LOYAL AS AN EMPLOYEE
AND SELF RESPECT I DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY THAT SHE WOULD FEEL
THE PRESSURE TO COME TO WORK
AND GET EVERYONE ELSE SICK JUST
BECAUSE HE COULD RECEIVE A
PAYCHECK OFF MY HAND SIDE IN
APRIL OF LAST YEAR FROM COLD
THAT. PARTLY BECAUSE HER BOSS
IN TO WORK- AFTER. BEING
EXPOSED TO COLD IT. THANK YOU
COULD RECEIVE A- IN FACT MY
YOUNG- OFF HAD AMPLE. AND MY
PARENTS SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE HI MY FROM WORK. AND A
BUNCH OF BUT THEY DO NOT
RECEIVE. HER WORKING THE- AT
HER JOB AND UNFORTUNATELY HE
COULD. CO THAT AND LATER DIED.
WITHOUT HIS SIXTEENTH MANY.
WORKERS HAVE NO CHOICE TO PUT
AWAY WHEN. OR PUT. INFECTIOUS
PUTTING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
COMMUNITY OUT READ. THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SAVE LIVES AND
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES. ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THIS IS SAMUEL MOLINA
CALIFORNIA STATE RECOGNITION
ONLY WELCOME RECALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STUDY
GRAY WHAT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
WITH UFCW WESTERN CAPE TOWN
HALL AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF OUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
LINE UFCW MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND TRUMP THE PORT EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR WORKERS NEED
EMERGENCY BASICALLY NOW MORE
THAN EVER WORKERS ARE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND I ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY FROM LOSING THEIR
HOMES THEIR CARS THEIR ABILITY
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. FROM
EVERYTHING MERGING THE
BASICALLY THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A WORKER BEING ABLE TO
STAY HOME TO PROTECT THEIR
COWORKERS AND EXPOSURE FOR
HAVING TO GO TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY NEED INCOME AN IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATION TO BE CUT AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ITEM I HAVE
A LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT
ABLE TO ATTEND THE HEARING BUT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT. NOTHING CLEARED
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL EDT I. L. CHINESE
PROGRESSIVE ASSOCIATION WALKING
INTO CLASS WORKERS CENTER SLOPE
CALIFORNIA MARQUIS DE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BOARD
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE BOARD I
SEE OUR O. NA COMMITTEE FOR
RECOGNITION OF NURSING IN
TREATMENT. I DROPPED THE
TRANSIT SAN FRANCISCO WAREHOUSE
WORKERS REPORT SENATE HE WALKED
THREE IN TOWN IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ALLIANCE AND PESTICIDE ACTION.
NETWORK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE IT. IN THIS.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN. I
THIS TIME. OVER TO ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CONNECTING MY
NAME IS MARIA AND HAPPY
HERNANDEZ I'M CALLING AND OF AB
EIGHTY FOUR I'M AN ATTORNEY I
LEGALLY AT WORK A NONPROFIT
THAT PROVIDES FREE LEGAL
EDUCATION ADVICE AND ADVOCACY
FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS ACROSSTHE
STATE. THE CONCERN OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HEARD FROM HUNDREDS
OF WORKERS IMPACTED BY CLOSE
THE NINETEENTH. WHEN THEY'VE
HAD ACCESS TO PAID SICK LEAVE
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO STAY HOME
AND STOP THE SPREAD. WHEN THEY
HAVEN'T THEY BEEN FORCED INTO
AN IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE OF MANY
HAVE BUT BEFORE EITHER GO TO
WORK AND READ WRITING HOLDEN
NINETEEN OR A HOME. I LOOK AND
COME AND THEIR JOB AND I'M SURE
YOU WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO
HEAR AND HAVE COURAGE THAT THEY
THAT TWENTY WORKERS HAVE CHOSEN
TO KEEP WORKING. ON JANUARY
FIRST FEDERAL PAID SICK LEAVE
AND BY EXTENSION STATE.
PERFORMANCE OF BASICALLY ENDED.
MANY OF THE WORKERS OF ONLY
THREE. PAID SICK. SENATE JUST
NOT ENOUGH TO RECOVER CORN.
BURKE FOR SICK FAMILY OR EVEN
TALKING- COVER. NATION OUR
ECONOMY ONE RECOVER UNTIL CAN
REAL. WE CANNOT REOPEN. ALL SIX
PARKS WORKERS ARE. TO GO. WORK
STUDY SHOW THAT PICKED. HOW
SAVED. AND AMERICA WE NEED THE
STATE TO ACT TO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS COME PUBLIC DIRECTOR OF.
DR PARTED COMPANY. AND STILL
THEIR INCOME AND JOB. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY ONE GO I.
GOOD MORNING UNITED FOR HUESO
HAN AND WHAT WORKING. FOR OR-
BUT IN SAN JOSE AND WE AN ARC.
TO PASS BECAUSE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX FOR ALL WORKERS EXTENDED.
IF YOU AND WE NOW WITH
COMMUNITY IN OTHER PARTS OF
STATE DO THE SAME THING ABOUT
HAVING PROTECT ALL FOR CERTAIN
WORKERS CONCERT CITIES. IT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH HE BE AS TO
EVERY STATE WHY. AND WE-
URGENTLY. FOR PEOPLE BE ABLE
AND EMPOWER TO STAY HOME IF
THEY'RE SICK OR QUARANTINE OR
RECOVERING FROM THE VACCINE-
BECAUSE OTHERWISE PEOPLE MAY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT
THEY WILL BE FORCED. IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEIR INCOME TO KEEP
THEIR FAMILIES HAVING LIVING TO
GO TO WORK OUT WHEN THEY SHE
SHOULD. NOT HAVE TO AND ARE NOT
ABLE TO. IN THIS. IS ABSOLUTELY
A EQUITY ISSUE. ARE MORE OF
COLOR. ARE OVERWHELMED THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS TO IT THAT ON
THE FRONT LINES TO THE PANDEMIC.
IT LOOKS LIKE. TO THE- MOSTLY
TO FALL ILL IN DYING TO ARE NOW
AT LEAST. I THINK IF YOU NOT.
THANK YOU. AND- PLEASE FOR THIS
ON WE JUST HAVE A THOSE P. WHO
HAVE INTO COULD YOU JUST SAY
YOUR NAME. AND ARE. AND THAT
USER. AT THIS OKAY. GO AHEAD MY-
THANK YOU BYE NINETEEN GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS COLLEEN GORGEOUS ON
THE PRESIDENT AND KRONOS THESE
ARE THE NURSES I RECOGNIZE AT
STANFORD CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
AND STANFORD HOSPITAL WE ARE IN
SUPPORT AND ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE SUPPORT YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THEN LET'S
THE CHECK IF THERE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE- WE'LL GO
FIRST TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THIS HEARING ROOM WHO IS
GOING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ANY OF THESE BILLS. SEEING NINE
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NOT
ALL RIGHT- TELEPHONE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE- QUEUE UP.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AND WE WILL
START OUT WITH THE FIRST YOU
KNOW AS WE JUST DID BEING ABLE
TO GIVE A MINUTE. AND AT A
CERTAIN POINT WILL CUT IT OFF
TO JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION
THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SIX ONE
ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE MODERATOR
GO AHEAD OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THIS TIME. AND
WHAT WHAT SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KEVIN TO DRIVE ANYWHERE. NF WE
ARE OPPOSED TO AB FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY
THREE PLEASE AHEAD. THIS IS
ACTUALLY OFTEN ON BUT OF THE K.
CHAMBER. PERSON FOREMOST THEY
WANTED LEADER FOR A MANY OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY'S CONCERNS
ABOUT EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHTY
FOUR MARCH TWELFTH AMENDMENT WE
STILL HOWEVER HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE CONTINUED PRESSURE TO
USE CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS OF
THE SAFETY NET FOR THE STATE'S
COGAN NINETEEN RESPONSE
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE CAL OSHA
REGULATIONS. ALREADY MANDATE
THAT ANY EMPLOYEE WITH BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN OR WHO HAS BEEN
EXPOSED THAT WORK MUST BE OUT
FOR A MINIMUM OF TEN DAYS
BEFORE PAID BENEFITS AND FULL
BENEFIT. MOST CONCERNING IS A
PROVISION MAKING THAT FREE OF
OBLIGATION RETROACTIVE TO
JANUARY FIRST IN A TIME WHEN
EMPLOYERS ARE CAREFULLY
PLANNING HOW THEY WILL SPEND
EVERY PENNY TO PREPARE FOR THE
FUTURE AND ENSURE THEY CAN
COVER PAYROLL AN EMPLOYER COULD
BE INUNDATED WITH REQUESTS FOR
A RETROACTIVE PAYMENT. FURTHER
THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS WILL
NOT COVER THE ENTIRETY OF THE
COST MOST OF THE QUALIFYING
REASONS ARE CAPPED THE FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT AT TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS A CAP OF.
FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN DOLLARS PER
DAY FOR EVERY QUALIFYING.
RETROACTIVE THAT. IS ALSO A
MASSIVE. BURDEN IT'S NOT CLEAR
HOW AN EMPLOYEE REGRET. THIS
WATER THE CITY. WHERE AN
EMPLOYEE WITHOUT IN JANUARY AND
YOU PGO SICK LEAVE OR VACATION
ANDNOW BECAUSE THEY ARE OWED
RETROACTIVELY UNDER THE BELT.
ANY ERROR WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
PAGA PENALTIES. FINALLY THE
RETROACTIVITY PROVISION RAISES
CONCERNS ABOUT LIABILITY ANY
EMPLOYEE OR FORMER EMPLOYEE WHO
BELIEVES THERE NOW- BRIDGES
FROM JANUARY FEBRUARY OR EARLY
MARCH. ARE YOU THIS MANDATE NOW
ALSO TRIGGERS PENALTIES UNDER
THE LABOR CODE. AND WE
REQUESTED THAT THE BELL THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY SAY THAT
EMPLOYER COULD NOT BE PENALIZED
BASED ON THE RETROACTIVE NATURE
OF THE BELT BUT THAT REQUESTED
UNFORTUNATELY TONIGHT.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY LEADS THE
NATION IN COVER NINETEEN
RELATED EMPLOYMENT LAWSUITS
EMPLOYERS SIMPLY CANNOT TAKE
ANY MORE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EDT FOR.
THANK YOU. NEXMO THANK YOU NINE
TWENTY NINE CALL. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
CA ACTOR CORP- WITH THE CAL
DENT SO- BASED ON THE PASSAGE
OF THE FED LAW IN THE RECENT
AMEND CITY WELL BE REMOVING OUR
OFFICE WE PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR NEXT THANK YOU I
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF UP BEYOND A
HEALTHCARE WEALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER AND THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ASSOCIATION BILL WE DO WANT TO
POINT OUT SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS THE
HITI S. RATES ARE PARK
INFLEXIBLE AND WILL NOT BE- BIG
EXPANDED UPON IN ORDER TO COVER
THE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT THIS
BILL WILL BRING TO US- BEAR BY
HURTING OUR IN HOME. CARE
SERVICES FOR MANY PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR NEXT THANK
YOU I'M TRYING TO GO AHEAD.
RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS CHRIS WAS TALKING WITH
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JUST AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTY FOUR I
AND OUR VIEWS ARE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE CAL CHAMBERS COMMENT.
RESTAURANT IN FINANCIALLY
DEVASTATED BY COULD NINETEENTH
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY COMPLYING
WITH LEAD MANDATE ANY
ALLEGATION EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
STANDARD. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BRIAN LITTLE BLOOD
MUGGY MORNING- IT WAS A
COMEDIAN AND MADAM CHAIRMAN
SPRY LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WE'RE IN A
POSITION TO AB EIGHTY FOUR FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY-
CALCHAMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JAMIE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
THAT WERE STILL OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
A MEMBER DISCUSSION SENATOR
NIELSEN YOU HAD YOUR MIKE UP
BEFORE NOT OKAY- ALL RIGHT. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER DISCUSSION ON
THE FLOOR CENTER NIELSEN YOU DO
WANNA MAKE COMMENT GO AHEAD. GO
AHEAD SATURDAY ALSO. A THE
MANAGER I'D LIKE TO JUST.
RESTATE THE OBJECTION I MADE
EARLIER ABOUT THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE THAT TESTIFIED. THEY
DO NOT MATCH THE FULL LIST OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED OR
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE PUBLISHED
MY POINT IS THAT THEY'VE GT
BEEN BLINDSIDED WITH THIS
WEEKEND DEAL. WHERE THEY HAVE
NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY RALLY THE TROOPS. AND
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE THE
JOINT OPINION OF THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS. LOL THIS BILL
ACTUALLY- PERCH SOME BUSINESSES
THAT DIED DEFINING. WHAT AID
FOR AN EMPLOYEE DOES NOT
INCLUDE. THAT'S A RATHER
INTERESTING PROVISION I WOULD
STATE MILDLY AND I KNOW WHAT
IT'S PURPOSES AND YOU TO. I
THINK THAT'S UNFORTUNATE AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE GRIEF AFFECTING SO
MANY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S SUCH A
SHABBY MANNER. SO I DO OBJECT
TO THIS ON THE RIGHT. THE PART
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID YOU
WANT TO COMMENT TO THAT. YOU
SEE THE HAND UP FUNCTION GO
AHEAD. EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I ACTUALLY WAS GOING TO
RESPOND BACK TO SENATOR GROVES
EARLIER QUESTION FOR THE
CITATIONS FOR HER QUESTIONS
OKAY BE TO FOLLOW UP WITH STAFF
AFTER PROVIDED NOW WHATEVER IS
EASIEST. ARE YOU COULD DO SO
NOW. THANK YOU SO SENATOR GROW
TO YOUR QUESTION WITH REGARDS
TO THE EIGHTY HOURS- LIMIT.
THAT IS IN SECTOR SECTION TO
FORTY EIGHT POINT TWO. LITTLE
BE. TOO BIG A- AND THEN FOR
YOUR CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO
THE PAGA ENFORCEMENT- THAT IS
IN THE SAME SECTION TO FORTY
EIGHT POINT TWO LITTLE EASY. TO
BIG DAY THERE'S A SECTION ON
THE RETROACTIVITY AND THE
COMPLIANCE THERE AND I COULD
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT WITH THAT
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE THOSE
CITATIONS IN WRITING. THAT
WOULD BE A WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR POINTING THAT OUT
ALL START LOOKING FOR THAT
RIGHT NOW IN THE MEANTIME COULD
YOU JUST BRIEFLY EXPLAIN TO ME
WHAT YOU WHAT YOUR
INTERPRETATION THAT IS. WHAT
I'D LIKE TO HEAR IF POSSIBLE IS
THAT- I'M JUST GONNA SAY WHEN
THIS BILL PASSES BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S GOING TO PASS. AND
WHEN THIS BILL PASSES IF AN
EMPLOYEE SAYS HEY BACK IN
JANUARY. I HAD CO BETTER MY MOM
HAD COVE IT. AND I WANT TO BE.
PAID FOR THAT TWO WEEKS OR THAT
EIGHTY HOURS- FIVE EVEN THOUGH
THEY- MAY NOT HAVE TAKEN THE
WHOLE TIME OFF I DON'T I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S JUST PAID SICK
LEAVE WHETHER THEY TOOK THE
TIME OR NOT. BECAUSE IT'S
RETROACTIVE. IF THE IF THEY DO
USE THAT. IN THE EMPLOYEE GETS
PAID EVERY TWO WEEKS AND THAT
PAY PERIOD FALLS THE NEXT PAY
PERIOD FALLS IN. APRIL WHICH IT
VERY WELL MAY BE. IS THERE ANY.
OF TI'S ASSOCIATED WITH AN
ACCURATE WAGE STATEMENTS LABOR
CODE SECTION TWO TWO SIX
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. WITH THIS
BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYER TO PAY PENALTIES AND
BE SUBJECT TO PENALTIES AND
FINES. FOR NOT PAYING THAT TWO
WEEKSWHEN THE EMPLOYEE
ACTUALLY TOOK THE TIME OFF BACK
IN JANUARY. BECAUSE IT WASN'T
REQUIRED TO BE PAID. UNDER THIS
BILL THAT TAKES EFFECT IN APRIL
OR MARCH THAT MAKES SENSE. YES
OKAY SO TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR THAT THERE IS
NO PENALTIES AGAIN ONLY IF. THE
EMPLOYER DOESN'T ROOM- ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AND SO. IF THEY
WERE TO TAKE THE LEAVE. BACK
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF THIS
BILL AND NOW WITH THE ENACTMENT
OF THIS BILL THEY CLAIM THAT
THAT TIME WAS TAKEN
SPECIFICALLY FOR CULTIVATED.
THEN THE EMPLOYER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THEN PROVIDE
THAT LEAVE FOR THEM
RETROACTIVELY ONLY IN THE CASE
WHERE THEY DON'T. PROVIDE THAT
THEN ENFORCEMENT WOULD TAKE
AFFECT AND HERE EARLIER
QUESTION ON THE EXPLANATION FOR
THE EIGHTY HOURS IT'S MY IT'S
AS I STATED THAT THE SECTION
SPECIFICALLY SAYS EIGHTY HOURS
FOR THE ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEES.
UNDER THAT SECTION. AND FOR
THAT THE OTHER- CONCERNS WITH
THE RETROACTIVITY- QUICKLY
LOOKING AT THAT NOW- THAT
SECTION IT SPECIFIES FOR ANY
FOR ANY SEXUALLY TAKEN IF THE
EMPLOYER DOES NOT COMPENSATE IN
THE FULL AMOUNT EQUAL OR
GREATER TO THE AMOUNT OF. THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE.
THEN- THE EMPLOYER SHALL. THEY
SHOULD BE PROVIDING THEM THAT
RETROACTIVITY PAYMENT AND SO IF
THEY DON'T COMPLY WITH THAT
THEN THE ENFORCEMENT DOES TAKE
EFFECT. IS THERE A DISPUTE
MECHANISM WHAT IF THE EMPLOYER
DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT THE
EMPLOYEE ACTUALLY TOOK THE
COVERT LEAVE FOR COVERT
SITUATIONS IN PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THERE WAS A DISPUTE
WITH THE EMPLOYER. I MEAN THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER HAD TO SAY
LOOK HE'S BEEN EXPOSED- HE
SHE'S BEEN EXPOSED TO COLLUDED-
AND SHOULD THEREFORE
QUARANTINE- IS THERE ANYTHING
LIKE THAT THAT'S A DISPUTE OR
DUE PROCESS FOR THE EMPLOYER OR
IS IT JUST AUTOMATICALLY ON
DEMAND FOR ANYBODY THAT SAYS.
THAT THE- WANT THAT TIME OFF
YES SO THIS DOESN'T THIS
DOESN'T DIFFER FROM ANY OTHER
SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS THEY ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
NOTIFICATION ALTHOUGH- ONE MAY
BE. ONE MAY BE ASKED FOR THE-
THE INPUT FROM THE EMPLOYEE- IN
ORDER TO PAY FOR THAT BUT- THIS
IS THE COMPLIANCE OR THE
ENFORCEMENT AS IT IS SIMILAR TO
EXISTING PAID SICK LEAVE
PROVISIONS. OKAY SO THERE IS NO
ABILITY TO ASK BECAUSE THAT'S-
I BELIEVE A VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW FOR- HIT BACK IF THEY CAN'T
SIMPLE YEAH OKAY SO THERE'S NO
ABILITY ASK. AND THEN- DID YOU
WORRY I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE
TO THOSE QUESTIONS WERE YOU
ABLE TO FIND OUT ANYTHING ON
THE ONE TO ONE MATCH. BECAUSE
LIKE I SAID I KNOW THE STATE
HAS A FIVE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
DOLLAR CAP- OR A TOTAL OF FIVE
THOUSAND WHATEVER. AT BUT THIS
FEDERAL BILL SAYS TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN MOST CASES OF THE
THREE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE WOULD COME FROM THE
EMPLOYER WITHOUT A TAX
REIMBURSEMENT. CORRECT OR NOT-
I'M SORRY I'M NOT I'M NOT AWARE
OF THE DISCREPANCY THE FACT
THAT CAPS THAT WE DECIDED
BEFORE AND I'M- I BELIEVE I
SAID REFLECT TENANTS IT'S FIVE
ELEVEN SO POLICIES. BY THE-
THEY SHOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT'S IN THE FEDERAL BILL.
THEY SHOULD BE OKAY THEY ARE
COULD THEY ARGUED THAT THE
CALORIE CONSISTENT WITH. THE
FEDERAL BILL THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S SEE IF
THERE ARE OTHER- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND WHAT WHAT WHAT I'M
GONNA DO NOW IS SEE IF WE HAVE-
I WANT TO GO THROUGH THE BILLS
IN THE ORDER THAT THEIR OWNER
GENDA. SO WE'RE AB EIGHTY THREE
THE LICENSE RENEWAL FEE CLEAN
UP THAT ALLOWS FOR THE CRAFT
BREWERS CRAFT DISTILLERS A FEW
OTHERS. TO BE ABLE TO ALSO- AND
RECEIVE THE- SUSPENSION ON
LICENSE PAYMENT- LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTION OR COMMENT
AND THEN LET'S TAKE A MOTION ON
AB EIGHTY THREE. ANY QUESTION
OR COMMENT SEEING NINE WE GOT
WHO US IN THIS SEGMENT DID YOU
MOVE IT OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MISS EGGMAN FOR AB
EIGHTY THREE. A SENATOR EGGMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. MISTER
STEPPING OF WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU OKAY. LET'S MAKE SURE IS
HIKES ON. GO AHEAD AB EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER HI.
NIELSEN. HI CORTESE RIGHT
COURTESY I DOLLY. THE RAZA HI
RATHER ALL RIGHT. EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE BRO HI I. KAMLAGER PLAYER
ALL RIGHT HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
HI MELENDEZ I MAN MAN I NEWMAN
AYE NEWMAN AYE. TOTAL BY THE
TERRIBLE HI. CAN I AM FINE
STERN BY CAL SKI. THIRTEEN I
THIRTEEN HOURS AGO WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN THERE ARE FEW
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPENS- AND NOW WE WILL
GO TO THE NEXT BILL ON FILE
ORDER AB. EIGHTY FOUR. IS THERE
A MOTION ON AB EIGHTY FOUR. THE
SENATOR CORTESE IS MOVED AND-
THE MOTION IS ALSO I DO PASS
SO- LET'S DO ROLL CALL ON AB
EIGHTY FOUR. AB EIGHTY FOR THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER HI NIELSEN NO
NOTHING NO CABALLERO HI. HI
CORTESE QUICKLY THE- DOLLY. THE
RAZA OUTSIDE RUN FIVE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH NO GROWTH NO.
I'M LONGER KAMLAGER. LAYERED HI
HI MCGUIRE AYE WIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO LINDA IS NO MAN BY
MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I THE OF
ALL WE SHOULD KNOW THE JOB NO
PAN HI HERE HI STERN. LIKE
GOING TO CALL FOR CALM SHE'S
HERE. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI. I
BELIEVE THAT'S A LOT FOR. THREE
OF ELEVEN I FOR NO BUT WE WERE
HOLD A KEY THAT BILL CALL FOR
THOSE MEN DURING. NOW WE WILL
GO TO AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE GOAL
STEM COOLEY UP SOME OF BMO BY
SENATOR DRAWS SO. FIVE PLEASE
THE ROLL. AB EIGHT THE MOTION
PASS CENTER SKINNER HI SKINNER
I NIELSEN. COPY BY I COURTESY
EIGHT FORTY THE HIGH. DOLLAR
GARAGE HI RUSSELL HI EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN HI GROW. KAMLAGER COMMA
HI LAYERED HI LAYERED I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA. MAN FIVE
MIN I NEWMAN RIGHT NOW I TOLD.
I THE TROUBLE HI PAN. IN HI
STERN LIKE OWSKI. THIRD BELIEVE
THAT SAID TWELVE TO- ZERO THREE
NOT VOTING WE WILL ALSO HOLD
THAT OPEN- SO- MAYBE WE COULD
HAVE THE- SERGEANTS THAT LET.
LET ARE MISSING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW TO COME TO THE
FLOOR SO THAT THEY CAN- WE CAN
REOPEN THE ROLE AND CLOSE THESE
OUT. THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. I
THINK THERE'S JUST A FEW
MEMBERS IN COMMITTEE. AND WHILE
WE ARE WAITING FOR THOSE
MEMBERS COME BACK ON TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AND IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO GET TESTIFIED SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO OUR BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE WHICH YOU CAN
SUBMIT- THROUGH OUR WE HAVE AN
EMAIL PORTAL ON OUR WEBSITE- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
AND- WE WILL JUST- HOPE OUR
OTHER MEMBERS- DOWN SO I CAN RE
OPEN. THE ROLE. YEAH. ALRIGHT
NUMBER YEAH. MMHM. BURKE YEAH.
I KNOW HE WAS I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE IS. ALL RIGHT I'M TO
RE. I KNOW THAT SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HE'S STILL GOING TO JOIN
US BUT HE'S PRESENTING A BILL
BUT ALL OPEN THESE UP BECAUSE
WE HAVE SENATOR DOLLY AND
SENATOR COM LONGER HERE SO
LET'S RE OPEN THE ROLE FOR AB
EIGHTY THREE. WHICH IS THE
LICENSE RENEWAL FEE CLEAN UP
FOR AND- ADD SOME OF OUR CRAFT
BREWERIES CRAFT DISTILLERIES IT
CETERA SO- MISTER KING- SURGERY
COMMITTEE- ACTUALLY CONSULTANT
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THOSE
MISSING MEMBERS THIS IS ON AB
EIGHTY THREE. AB EIGHTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. SENATORS
DOLLY. ALI COME ON. KAMLAGER
FIVE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI STERN
BY CAL SKI- I WILL STILL HOLD
IT OPEN BUT LET'S MOVE TO AB
EIGHTY FOR THE PAID SICK LEAVE
LET'S OPEN THAT ROLE. CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS AB EIGHTY FOR
THE MOTION TO PASS SENATORS
DOLLY. DOLLY NO. STERN LIKE
OWSKI- I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
WILL GO TO AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE-
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS CLEAN UP
WHICH THE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS. DOLLY-
THIRD ALI NOT VOTING. STERN MY
COUNTY OKAY SO- JUST HOLD OFF
FOR A FEW MINUTES AND HOPEFULLY
MISTER WORK HOURS HE WILL HAVE
HIS- BILL PRESENTATION WRAPPED
UP. WHILE FIREFIGHTERS WERE. IF
CENTER.
THIRTY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEYS ONLY GOT A FEW MORE
MINUTES LEFT ON HIS BILL SO WE
ARE GOING TO LET HIM WRAP HIS
BILL UP. AND LET HIM COME DOWN
AND OUT ON TO THE ROLE. SO WE
WILL. CONTINUE THE COMMITTEE
UNTIL MR CALLACE CAN CAN COME
DOWN.
GOOD IDEA THE.
YEAH. THE.
A.
YEAH. THE. YEAH. UHHUH
ACTUALLY ABSENT TODAY OR ON I'M
ASSUMING LIKE GIRLS JUST BROKE
AS EXPECTED SO PS CISTERN
WORKOUTS WITHOUT.
YOU CAN BE
ANYWHERE MISTER Y. CASKEY
ALRIGHT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE'S
GOING TO REOPEN SOME BILLS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN HOLDING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR TWO MISSING MEMBERS SO
LET US START WITH THAT CALL THE
ROLL FOUR YES AB AB. EIGHTY
THREE. AB EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS SENATORS
STERN. RIGHT STERN HI MY COUNTY
HI KATHY HI ALL RIGHT THAT BILL
PASSES WITH EIGHTEEN. I VOTES
ZERO NUMBER EIGHTEEN AYE VOTE
ZERO NOTES THAT TV EIGHTY THREE
WE WILL NOW GO TO AB EIGHTY
FOUR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS STERN AYE STERN
HI. MY COUNTY. BY COUNTY HI.
PROBABLY A NAP BILL PASSES WITH.
THIRTEEN AYE VOTES THIRTEEN AYE
VOTES FIVE NO VOTES FIVE NO
VOTES RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO TO
THE FINAL BILL AB EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR. THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
CLEAN UP. FOR A MISSING MEMBERS
CALL THE ROLL AB EIGHTY EIGHT
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS SENATORS
STERN AYE STERN HI MY COUNTY HI
MY COUNTY HI VERY GREAT THAT
BILL PASSES. RATING FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN AYE VOTES FOURTEEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT AND ZERO NO
VOTES. ALRIGHT WITH THAT ALL
THE BILLS ARE OUT. AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW WILL NOW DURING.